أنا أؤمن بالمثل العظيمة لهذا
البلد من أجل عدالة الحرية
والسعي وراء
السعادة وأستيقظ كل يوم وأنا أعمل من
أجل أن يكون هناك أطفال صغار مثلي
يجلسون في مخيمات اللاجئين
ويجدون أنفسهم بلا
آمال وأحلام حيث  يخبرهم الجميع
أن الشيء الوحيد الذي
يجب أن يفكروا فيه هو المكان الذي
يجب أن يأتي منه دلوهم التالي من المياه النظيفة
ومن أين ستأتي وجبتهم التالية
وما إذا كانوا ينامون في
ملجأ يبعدهم عن الشمس
و  المطر وأفكر في ما إذا كان
طفلي البالغ من العمر ثماني سنوات يعرف ويعلم عن
هون الذي كان في مخيم للاجئين في الثامنة
وأصبح ممثلًا للدولة الذي
كان سيعطيني الكثير من
الآمال والكثير من الأشياء التي يجب أن
أتطلع إليها  إلى و وأعتقد أن الوقت الذي
أواجهه هو حقًا بالنسبة لأولئك الذين تبلغ
أعمارهم 80 عامًا أكثر بكثير مما هو عليه بالنسبة لي